can now order free covet test kits
through the government's new website the
official launch of covettest.gov was set
for tomorrow but the white house quietly
rolled it out today at home testing is
considered a key tool in the battle
against the virus but those tests are
hard to come by in some places
tests allow us to make decisions about
whether we're contagious and so a threat
to others whether we can safely return
in person to school or to work
the tests are limited to four per
household now the process is very easy
very simple all you have to do is enter
your name and delivery information more
than 5.4 million americans tested
positive for covid last week now that's
a new record during this omicron fueled
surge
in addition to those tests governor
steve sisalek says nearly 600 000 kits
will also be delivered to nevada by the
end of the month thanks to federal
coveted relief funds they'll be
distributed all across the state with
most of the tests going to places like
health care clinics libraries and fire
districts